okay so you wrote about the dark triad
in psychology today and in quillette
and i believe it was psychology today oh
yeah dark personalities are more likely
to signal victimhood
so
so that surprises me a bit because i
always thought that it was more
agreeable people
that tended towards
being victims but that's not what this
suggests
well it's it's a little bit tricky so
the that paper was a fascinating
paper i think was published in 2020 in
the journal of personality and social
psychology
uh
you know a series of very interesting
studies
and they weren't claiming so the
researchers were not claiming based on
the studies that they ran that
actual victims score higher on dark
triad personality traits
what they were claiming is that people
who tend to score high on dark triad
personality traits tend to signal
victimhood more and signaling victimhood
is not necessarily the same thing as
actually being a victim right and so
people who are truly
um
sort of the the targets of misfortune or
suffering have really gone through bad
things those aren't the people who you
know tend to be narcissists or
psychopaths but the people tend to be
narcissists and psychopaths uh will sort
of exploit people's empathy and sort of
exploit people's willingness to help
suffering people uh by by playing a
victim
and so
you know of course they ran the the
standard um dark triad uh scales sort of
asking people there there's questions
about how they um interact with other
people and how they move through the
world whether they tend to be cold and
calculating and so forth whether they're
sort of believe themselves to be more
important than other people but then
they also created a victim a victim
signaling scale
and it included items like you know i
tend to uh
want to broadcast that people like me
are are sort of not as well known as we
should be or how you know more people
who are like me need to be
represented in the media or or um
in
sort of the public conversation
basically like you know they're they're
they're put upon they're sort of
suffering in some way
and
they tend to highly correlate so the
higher you are in dark triad the more
signaling you do um in terms of
victimhood signaling so
they also found some interesting it
wasn't just correlational studies so
they weren't just administering scales
and finding that they tended to
correlate they were also doing
experimental studies as well um
basically in one of the studies what
they did was uh the the psychologists
rigged a game in which participants
could uh win some money but what the
psychologist did was um rigged it so
that it was really easy to cheat and it
was really easy for them to figure out
who cheated
and first they had people play this game
uh they tracked who cheated in the game
to win more money um and they also had
these participants take the um the dark
triad personality scale and they found
that the people who scored highly on the
scale also were more likely to cheat to
win more money at this game
um
they also did these interesting studies
where they um basically imagine the
participants to envision themselves in
um
in a sort of an employment scenario so
they have a colleague at work who and
they're described as being a little bit
unpleasant to be around and maybe they
don't like them very much and so on so
this is the person they're imagining but
then the researchers asked the
participants um
you know
uh how much do you agree with these with
these items these statements like you
know this colleague insults you all the
time this colleague has taken advantage
of you and all of these things the this
this colleague has done bad things to
you his colleague needs to be fired
nothing in the description of this
person in this sort of scenario
indicated that they had ever insulted
the participant that they had ever um
done anything wrong to them but they
basically the scenario was like this
person just don't like them very much
right
um and again the researchers found that
people who score high on dark trad are
more likely to exaggerate or fabricate
negative qualities about this other
person uh and say how bad badly they've
been treated by them
huh i wonder if they actually believe
that or not has there been any like is
it full-on lying is it is it to get
somewhere or do they switch that in
their head so they think that they've
been insulted
yeah i don't even know if uh like it's
an interesting question
but
you know i'm not i may not matter
because the outcome is such that this is
how they behave
and
you know the the researchers uh in that
paper you know they document how you
know
uh findings from from insurance fraud
claims right like you know some some x
number of millions or billions of
dollars every year
are lost because of people who are
fraudulently filing insurance claim you
know people who
claim that they can't seek employment
and so basically a lot of people will
sort of exploit weaknesses and various
systems in order to extract economic
gain or whatever kind of gain happens to
be
but you know people who score highly on
the dark triad they are they tend to be
more preoccupied with with status with
sexual rewards so material rewards
social rewards sexual rewards
and
whatever environment they happen to find
themselves in
they will
enact the strategies to extract those
rewards so if they happen to be say in
you know the modern west in the year
2022 they might find that oh the best
strategy to extract rewards is to signal
victimhood
and so that's what they'll do to sort of
uh exploit the weaknesses in the system
but if they're somewhere else you know
maybe being an extreme narcissist might
be the best way to do it so they'll sort
of lean into that and that's the best
way to to get attention to get
romantic partners or whatever it happens
to be so they tend to be very good um at
sort of picking up on you know what are
the
what are the ways uh to maximize those
rewards in whatever social environment
they happen to be in
okay so
that's very interesting but
that type of person sounds like an
unattractive type of person right anyone
who's signaling victimhood without
actually being a victim i don't think
anyone finds that attractive
however
according to what like what you wrote
women are more attracted to people who
score higher in these dark triad
personality traits
yeah well
that was a study um i want to see us
from 2015 uh his team of researchers
they
had some women evaluate
a man
basically his suitability as a romantic
partner
and what they found is that men who
score highly on the dark triad relative
to an ordinary man so an average guy
versus a guy who's really high on the
dark triad they score the the dark triad
guy um to be quite a bit more attractive
so one standard deviation more
attractive than the average and a
standard deviation is is a lot in in
psychological research that sort of
that gap
i'd imagine i can't remember the
specific details of how they sort of
characterized this guy this dark triad
guy but i'd imagine they weren't saying
like he you know talks about how he's a
victim or whatever yeah um they probably
talk about how he tends to be um sort of
superficially charming and maybe a
little bit callous and uncaring and
emotionally distant and these kinds of
things and
something else i i had written in that
in that article sort of summarizing a
lot of this research um
justin lay miller who's a sexual
psychologist uh wrote a book called tell
me what you want about uh sexual
fantasies
and he writes about how
uh the most fantasized about superheroes
among women
uh the most fantasized superhero is
batman
uh which is a an interesting contrast
with the most fantasized superhero among
gay men which which are uh captain
america and superman and i found that
kind of
that's that uh that difference to be
interesting right because like superman
and captain america are like these uh
goody two-shoes boy scouts like you know
these are the the guys that little boys
look up to as like the
the sort of like the the the the most
pure and noble superheroes and i think
batman is often seen as like this sort
of darker edgier
you know like almost like he's a villain
but he still does the right thing but
you could imagine him going to the dark
side and this is the guy that that women
you know of all the superheroes that's
the one that they seem to like the most
that's so funny
that's so funny i never liked captain
america just like that superman boring a
superman too well superman mostly
because it's like he he can do
everything
so he's just he's gonna win
right he's like okay
too old of a superhero there's no
weakness there what's his i guess
kryptonite's the weakness but i mean
come on
one thing i would be curious about i
don't have any research on this but um i
don't know did you see that new james
bond movie no time to die
is that the newest one the newest one
yeah it came out like a couple months
ago
okay no i haven't i really want to see
that have you seen it yeah yeah i
thought it was good it's not like the
best james bond ever but i i thought it
was really good um but one of the things
that's interesting about the this the
bond series is how like the sort of the
earlier bond movies were sort of more um
campy a little bit there was a little
bit more humor in there but starting
with the latest bond with daniel craig
uh like the series took this more sort
of darker edgier turn and the daniel
craig bond
um he he gets injured more
he's more vulnerable he gets beaten up
um you can sort of see the physical
effects throughout the movie of him sort
of becoming more and more damaged and he
himself is sort of a more edgy and rough
character and i would love to see you
know if there's any data on like maybe
30 years ago whoever was born 30 years
ago how did women feel about that bond
versus the bond today and see like if
which james bond is like the most
appealing to to women or to viewers in
general
yeah or if that
has changed right i mean maybe it was
the same percentage of women back then
as it is now but women now don't find
that attractive oh that's a good point
too
[Music]